ديما
lancelot كل ما يمكن أن نأخذه
إضافة أنا مدين لم يبق على
سوف أبقى سخيف في كل أنواع ليس الشواذ
اللعنة الكلبة التكنولوجيا جميع
هنا تذهب أيتها العاهرة
تعال يمارس الجنس مع العاهرة قبلنا اللعين
اللعنة
ضجيج لك أيتها العاهرة لحفر كل الماء اللعين
اللعين اللعين
الكلبة لن أندم على حياتي اللعينة
يمارس الجنس مع هؤلاء الشواذ
الكلبة أنطونيو ثم كل شيء بالقرب من منزلي
كنت لأعطي
أنتون وتستهلك
لم أبق في خيوط الديون حتى تاريخ اليوم
شارك في تأليف ذلك
هذا ما نأخذه منهم بيتر الشارع كله
سخيف محطة سخيف Kadyrovtsy
جاءت طقوس المرور بمثابة هجوم سخيف على ذلك الشخص
طقوس الداعر المعتادة الخفيفة هذا ما
الثلج لبقية المشي هذا ما
كل ما تبقى هو أن يمارس الجنس
يمارس الجنس مع بعض الشواذ قطع الغيار
أندونا سخيف
كل شيء عن طريق العطر في عمل جيد تجبركم
أتقنه
كانت جيدة جدا
هذا كله هراء
كل هذا هو الذباب اللعين
[موسيقى]